what's up guys it's 2018 and that can
mean only one thing
MLB the show a teen Ramon Russell is
back yep and we're gonna go through some
some new features yeah let's just get
right into gonna get right into it you
know we're gonna talk about today I'm
not sure I'm in the dark let's got a lot
of stuff so you seen the trailer which
just came out right now changing all of
the really cool stuff that we kind of
hidden it I got a box behind my hiding
the scene so by the time you guys see
this the trailer will be out it'll all
make sense so today what we're gonna
talk about in this visit is gameplay
gameplays King games Before we jump in
the gameplay role to the show it's going
to be amazing this year we've done a lot
of big changes to roll the show we're
not gonna talk about the seat can't
share any of that to share that today
today we talk about gameplay so what why
gameplay well you know what's what's
baseball right pitching hitting fielding
catching and throwing right that that's
the core pillars of a baseball game so
we spent a lot of developmental
resources this year on working on those
core systems for instance our tagging
engine has been completely rewritten
from the ground up right nothing from
last year's tagging engine is in the
game this year that should make a lot of
my fans happy because we had a few
issues in our tagging engine so what we
did was Jeff Ullman who wrote the base
runner code and base runner logic he
rewrote the entire tagging system it
kind of makes sense right the guy who
wrote the base runner logic should
probably rewrite the tactic and so what
that has allowed us to do is you know
before and any other MLB to show game
the fielder who had the ball who was
trying to tag a player out he didn't
quite have the spatial awareness of what
the other guy was trying to do we're
just trying to tag him he didn't know if
he was running he didn't know if he was
sliding now he knows those things so
when the ball is in playing the fielder
has the ball he knows what the runners
trying to do if he sees and he's going
for a dive it's like oh this guy's
diving I need to try to tag him here oh
right run it away from me I need to try
to tag him here so all of our tags now
are all contextual and so what that does
is one the game plays a lot smoother it
looks a lot better and it looks a lot
more realistic and it cuts out a lot of
exploits that you saw in preview
versions of the game oh nice catch let's
go and these tagging kind of updates
apply to all baseball base to first base
home they can't third every single base
like this is like the tagging system was
such a big core rewrite it's something
that you're gonna see take place by the
fifth game that you've played the third
game that you played run when you're 100
games in you're gonna continue to see
just how good our tagging system is
because the thing is with sports games
because we have real-life reference to
go off of if it doesn't look right you
immediately notice so that's one of the
big cory rights another big core
gameplay thing is since we're talking
about tagging catchers you know our
catchers couldn't quite get up out of
their crouches fast enough to deal with
runners trying to advance bases so when
there's a pass ball that doesn't quite
shoot 50 feet away from them right so
now you'll see and you saw you'll see
this in the trailer too like there's a
few scenes of the catcher exploding out
of his stance and getting to that ball
and last year you could probably take
second base because of a few of the
exploit that exploit set though right
all gone the catches are gonna get up
they're gonna get the ball and they're
gonna fire it out so you won't be able
to do kind of the weird stuff that you
did last year so now there's a chance of
gunning runners out it's not a chance if
you you try to do something that's
unrealistic that you wouldn't see in a
real baseball game like advancing from
first to second on a pass ball that's
like right in front of the catcher
you're gonna be thrown out you're gonna
get thrown out
same thing with if a ball does make it
past the catcher and makes it to the
backstop you know the pitchers gotta
Cove a home right right so we've worked
on a lot you know our lead animator
Chris Clemens Chris guild our league
gameplay lead what they've done is made
sure that we have enough animations for
the pitcher to be able to handle those
situations when he's covering home and
he needs to tag somebody out so you
won't see as much frustration there as
well right that goes to more like with
the gameplay and what you're gonna see
is it's so much smoother our guys are so
much more efficient they threw things so
much faster and they're able to get rid
of the ball even faster than they could
last year and it makes a huge
that was a nice little was that cureo
Giancarlo though that correct Karl it's
gonna be you gonna be happy to share
being a Yankees fan aren't you okay
great it's gonna be great we can use one
more starting pitcher one more starting
pitcher but then I'd be spoiled you know
yeah you got you know dudes gonna hit
200 home runs between the three air so
thing I don't think so I'm just throwing
this ball down in the middle cuz I want
to get some action I want to see some
balls put in play
so speaking of animations you know the
catcher we have over a hundred new
animations for the catcher and
everything that's going around when when
he can't take care of a ball and he gets
past them or just dribbles right in
front them so he has new animations
we've added a lot of new animations for
again the pitcher covering home and
we've always tried to fill holes where
we think we were kind of weak in years
past and I think we've continued that
trend on this year and that goes with
everything that's a nice little hit
speaking of hitting really big topic you
know last year was a huge update for us
we're going to our new physics engine
with spin and all that stuff we've
continued to refine that it's something
that was a big focus for us like we have
hitting play tests every single day all
the design team everybody in QA like
from 3:30 to 5:00 we'd go in the room
and we all just play the game and give
notes and feedback like okay this isn't
kind of feeling right we're not getting
enough singing we're not getting the
doubles and that's something that you're
gonna we're gonna continue till we
finish the game so we're really really
happy we're hitting is now but we're
gonna continue to try to make it better
bring we ship the game so something that
guys have probably noticed since we've
been playing is we've updated the swing
analysis box so now on certain swings
you'll actually see this 3d out this 3d
slide out in the bottom right in the
bottom right or left depend on hand in
step so there it is so that is in real
time what your swing did like that's
where the ball was in 3d space that's
where the bat is in 3d space so that's
all one-to-one so you can really come
out there so you can later understand
like did I really get that ball or was
that under it how early was her early
was I and that's something that uh Lance
has been working on all year and it's
starting to shape up pretty well
I mean it looks again it looks fantastic
I know last year was me maybe a major
focus on the looks of each player and
kind of the whether it was how their
faces loved how their stances were what
not can you talk about what kind of is
the overhaul the real main focus of this
year's show absolutely so last year was
like the faces right you know we
overhauled our entire face system you
know this year it's the uniforms right
you know a few years back the stadiums
got all of their faces got the love and
then along with the faces no we had the
body scale slabs that we had this year
it's all about the uniforms so our
physically based rendering system that
we brought to the stadiums and all of
those aspects like the medal and the
padding that's now came over to uniforms
right so when you see close-ups
close-ups of the uniforms they're gonna
look so much better
the stitching looks fantastic and our
character team and all the artists have
done a fantastic job really making the
uniforms pop right also when we
eventually start talking about creative
player there's a few other updates there
too as well in the graphics department
for you'll see a little bit of that in
the trailer is yes you will a little
ceiling you'll see something there's a
lot of stuff in the trailer all right we
think our biggest fans Bay to pick up on
and then stuff that people miss will
definitely run a berate it on I know you
mentioned a little earlier about kind of
stadium atmosphere obviously that was an
overhaul a couple games back but has
there been anything done to kind of
update this stadium oh absolutely a
crowd ambience presentation commentary
those are big areas of focus this year
so we're not ready to talk about
presentation and commentary but Kirby
st. John and Michael Compton and Ross
they've been working like crazy and I
think people are really gonna like what
they've done right so specifically about
the crowds one we've doubled our crowd
animations so now what you're gonna see
you're gonna see people like they'll be
taking sips out of cups they're gonna be
on the phone which seems to be this
thing we do in society a lot yeah you're
gonna see more people getting up our
attendance logic is now really really
close one-to-one to what you'll see in
real life and this is all data that we
gotten from the MLB so like the Dodgers
fans tends to show up a little bit later
the games because you know right late
traffic right that's gonna happen in the
game in this game we're playing right
here it's a fool like it just it's a
sellout right if we start getting blown
out by the six of the seventh inning the
crowd is going to start to leave and
these are some things that really make
like wrote to the show and season modes
that much better because you see how
dynamic the crowd is and not like
edition of realistic neces is something
that really stands out too I feel like
because nobody the stands not gonna be
full on the bottom of the ninth if
you're losing like like 21 yeah 3
everybody's gonna be going home and I
mean now you also noticed in the trailer
but also we can kind of see it here over
in right field
it looks like the cover athlete yeah
guns Chavez the judge's chambers is in
the game oh is this going into the
change chamber it's going on oh it's
closed it went out where did I get this
let's look at the swing analysis to see
so you see what I did here I was close
when to the bat and the bat I'm also
dead out yeah oh that's convenient we're
talking about that and you just saw a
little bit of the years she gonna be a
lot of home runs hitting the stadium
that's a guest that's that's just a wild
guess
yeah well here's one of our new cameras
so what's cool about this camera is
it'll trigger on some homeruns and foul
ball so you kind of won't know exactly
the 20 years right and how many of these
new camera angles have been added there
so for like I think we added about five
new batting cameras and we added cameras
based on the cameras that we saw a lot
of people were using so we try to give a
little
there you're gonna see a lot of new
cameras in the presentation aspect of
the game again won't talk about that too
much
one thing I will tell you is you know
Kirby and the guys have done a lot of
job with replays the commentary stuff
that I can't really talk about that but
it's gonna be we'll get there we'll get
their mental edge very soon very soon we
don't know what will
you'll find out soon ish I'm just in the
dark as much as everybody there's a lot
we have to talk about there's this
really cool new feature which we're
gonna make another video of that'll come
out a little bit after this one and this
is a feature that people have been
asking for for years like this is one of
the really really cool features that
people asked for we've also done a lot
of work with franchise mode we have this
thing called phases which we won't talk
about yet yeah so franchise mode has
phases wrote to the show you know Steve
murca and the designers have done a
really really awesome job of really
refreshing role to the show and giving
it that love cuz that was some of the
feedback we heard last year was oh well
you know tagging is not great
the catcher can't really you know play
his position away Franklin what are you
guys gonna hold the haul road there's
showing so this year all those big major
focuses around the things that the
community kind of thought we should
focused on the same things we thought we
should focus on so we think people will
be really excited about the game view I
mean any any group of fans that kind of
get the developers to focus on things
that they really want the game I think
is really fantastic because the end of
day look we want to make the best and
most enjoyable baseball game as well
like we're on the same team you don't we
don't want the game to have exploits or
to have weak areas and that's I think
that's something we've done a pretty
decent job of in the past is every
single gay okay where were we week last
year oh what is the feature that that
people really wanted and that we think
people are gonna see that again issue
and I'm sure that any like concerns of
players have is probably the same
concerns that you guys have as like the
developers again oh yeah absolutely
something's a lot easier to do than
others you know some things may take you
know two
three years for some work on the back
end but we we tend to get the things
yeah when we can so we also just saw
something that we teased in a trailer we
now have the mouth guards for the
helmets I also have something
accessories can't give you what all of
them are but you know we have some new
accessories and brands and categories
there so Springer and I think correct
it's a career that has the the mouth and
the Springer have it too he might I
don't allow the guys dr. back jack yeah
back to back jacks and I'm just laying
it in here so we can we can get some
games oh good swing time and good a
contact result good so pitching is a
little harder that's something I forgot
to mention it's not a huge difficulty
increase but we kind of felt maybe it
was a little bit too easy to pinpoint
right so you'll see some changes there
again hitting physics all those things
have been tuned it's something that
we'll be working on until we go cold
freeze to try to make sure you know the
hitting engine is just dialed in right
as it possibly can't be you know we have
hundreds of new fielding animations and
fulfilling outside of what we're trying
to do with tags and whatnot we wanted to
fill holes get some more throws we want
to make sure that guys can branch out of
things in case you got a guy on first
you got a guy on third right you've
sending the guy at first and then if
maybe if he's not paying attention I'm a
sitting this guy home maybe in last
year's game the second baseman couldn't
fire that ball home cuz he couldn't read
out right you won't have that problem
anymore you can pretty much branch out
of it anything and that really cuts down
on the exploits that we used to have it
right and this will obviously all play
into effect when when players are
playing online absolutely yeah a lot of
these things were shortcomings that we
saw online who you playing offline you
don't see it because you play notarize
the computer will kill you or if you're
playing against your buddy just like hey
man stop it like is he's sitting right
there you're sitting right there but you
know when you're in a realm of online
people tend to do you know weird stuff I
think the win that's I guess that's a
mentality that's always been around so
we've also updated to whether we redid
our fog we've read in our rain also got
something interesting to talk about with
rain in the future
cool I know last year there was kind of
a focus on the field
the grass as well were there any updates
for kind of those I think it was shadows
last year yeah so shadows is big this
year we're focusing in on the backdrops
for all of the minor league stadiums um
we really I think our stadium team went
and looked at every scene of minor
league stadium and looked at those
backdrops
I think they read it all over because if
you really wrote to the show you're
gonna be spending quite a bit of time
yeah and it knows my league stadiums we
really want to take those to the next
level so that's a nice update there and
that's a nod like swimmer
come on Brett it's a terrible swings go
to second anyway we'll pop up so one
thing you're not seeing at all because
we don't want to show is you're not
gonna see the new presentation stuff
because I'm on fast Morman keep that
stuff close to the chest secret keep
your coke like we don't want to spoil
all the stuff curving and working on
just yet you did see before the last
inning you saw one around the stadium
cutaways where will show more blimp
views of all of the state and star
stadiums look gorgeous you know those
guys work really hard so that's one of
the things you'll notice trying to that
can't give away too much I don't want to
spoil sport Kirby's fire see if I can
actually I mean just like it's almost
almost pitchers and catchers so they're
preparing they're about this rapport in
the game you're getting ready we're
getting ready to report again like game
play core gameplay systems I'm terrible
I'm striking out there's such a huge
focused issue you know pitching catching
throwing hitting all of those systems
got a lot of love this is easily the
most polished dialed in of gameplay that
we've ever done
and we everybody at Studios really proud
about that are there any other gameplay
highlights that you can you know fill us
in on that can be filled in I'm sure
there's a lot of other updates that are
coming down the road yeah so into the
show wonderful not like I mentioned
before because we were emulating a real
sport whenever something's off you
always notice he's like I saw that on TV
yeah it's not happening how it's
supposed to happen in the game right so
we spent a lot of time on emotion so for
the pitches and the hitters when guys
strike out when they draw a walk or when
the pitcher strikes somebody out or he
gets a call ways he's kind of perturbed
about it you'll see they're gonna emote
a lot more guys in the infield will
communicate more like you'll see like in
a trail you saw Trey turn something like
it is two hours you're gonna see so much
more of that going on there's so much
more post play what we call idle scenes
happening where guys are going to react
appropriately after route is made and
that's something you'll seem like oh
that's cool that's what I saw on TV and
it just makes sense now whereas maybe in
previous years of the game after an out
the guy would walk a weird way or he'd
do a real gesture like that doesn't that
doesn't look right and that takes you
out of the immersion of the game yeah I
mean anything that boosts the realistic
ness of the presentation you know we
like with like homerun swings and
backflips we got a lot more a lot more
of those all the guys that do them we
tried to recapture them so we probably
added another 25 plus of those okay and
in the creative player editor there's
quite a bit in there we know wrote to
the show's a very popular mode people
like to hit bombs and roll the show
we're not creating pictures so that has
so many more animations guys can choose
from to be able to show off their
personality I have some fingers crossed
there you're gonna be some deep bombs
and toss the bat up in the stand oh you
can do all that we got all that coverage
going the Jose Bautista
we got Utah Hubbard we got you covered
I'm excited all right well my thanks to
you Ramones for coming in showing us all
the gameplay updates for the show thank
you for inviting us we are pretty
excited to see what else is down the
road
chose awesome alright well we have our
fingers cross and keep it right here on
gamespot very soon we'll have some some
details with Ramon again so we'll see
you next time
[Applause]